I'm Bruce Shapiro executive director of
the dart Center for journalism and
trauma over at the Graduate School of
Journalism across the street the dart
Center is a resource center forum think
tank for journalists who cover violence
conflict and tragedy in all of their
manifold forms from street crime and
family violence up to war and human
rights and situations like those in
Russia um the dart Center is a
co-sponsor of this week's conference
we're very proud to be part of it and
grateful to Cathy for having us along
and to the Harriman Institute I'm going
to be very quick I get I have the great
pleasure of introducing two friends
their biographies are in the program I
won't go into that but i will say that a
big part of my own sense of Russia but
also of politics more broadly and of the
possibilities of journalism is owed to
the two women at this table Katrina
vanden Heuvel is an old friend and
colleague and for quite a few years my
boss at the Nation magazine and our
conversations going back a frightening
Lee large number of years now have a lot
to do with certainly how I think about
the issues that we've all been
discussing for the last couple of days
ajaja kina has never been my boss yet
somehow I can never say no to her the
Russian Union of Journalists has a
singular place and her work within it
has a singular place in advancing the
freedom of the press in Russia freedom
of expression the quality training
professionalism of Russian journalism
and standing tall for the promise of
speaking truth to power journalism which
holds those who have authority
accountable and does the job that
journalism can do at its very best for a
couple of years now
we've been kicking around this idea of a
public conversation between Katrina and
Naja who have actually themselves work
together since the days of perestroika
in various ways that they will perhaps
describe this is building the program as
an interview and Katrina will be
interviewing nadjib especially about
current events wonderful photograph on
the screen but somehow I think it's
going to be much more than an interview
it will be a conversation involving the
two of them and then perhaps all of us
so go for a little while and when you're
ready to engage others do so I'll just
say this now when you when we do get to
questions and answers use the mic their
lineup this is being recorded so nothing
you wouldn't want recorded for posterity
and give people your name's Katrina it's
yours thank you Bruce thank you for your
tenacity we have talked about doing this
for over two or three years and thank
you Bruce for giving me many lessons and
what it means to be somewhat of
independent spirit and caring about the
quality and independence of journalism
it is true Nagi and I have known each
other from Gorbachev perestroika to
Putin's Russia we didn't know each other
during Brezhnev stagnation but we will
talk about that but I want to sing
Nadia's a great friend and a great
journalist and a person a woman of
extraordinary extraordinarily
independent mind and spirit and her
experience which we'll talk about has
covered journalism from Brezhnev
stagnation to Gorbachev perestroika to
Yelton yeltsin's oligarchical Russia to
Putin's Russia we work together for many
years on a feminist newsletter called
voi em we and I wish Colette Shulman was
here because she really was the
inspiration and the founder and in doing
that we we learned a lot about the
limits of the Russian press when it came
to coverage of women's issues i brought
my bumper sticker from those years
democrat iya mean essentially yet
democratic democracy without women it's
not democracy recently in these last
five six seven years Nadia has been as
Bruce said executive director of the
union of Russian journalists and in that
capacity would I hope to talk to nod you
a little bit about today is how she has
traveled widely not just around the
world as she has but in interesting ways
around Russia and to the provinces of
Russia and in doing so has worked to
train journalists in the provinces
you've been working with Gregory's feed
off for many many years and has also I
think something that we forget with the
coverage of politics she's not only
worked to ensure the safety and freedom
of expression of journalists has been on
the front line of creating a data bank
which shall talk about cataloguing the
violations of killings and threads but
she's also worked on bread and butter
issues if one might call it that that
journalists get the pensions that
they're owed that there these are issues
that often don't get covered in this
country I just want to see briefly that
in many ways my relationship with Nadia
parallels my relationship with Russia
during the perestroika era Nadia worked
for one of the great glasnost editors
and one of the two flagships of
perestroika journalist called again York
she worked for vitaly chaotic some of
you may remember that name and i was
able in a very much humbler way to work
at moscow news not Moscow Times but
Moscow news edited by Igor yakovlev and
they were the two great editors and what
you Gor and I know Nigel feels this way
about cottage would they taught us was
the courage and determination to push
the limits of a then diminishing
censorship under glasnost but a still
existing censorship and to push the
taboos that still existed despite the
hostility this aroused among enemies of
perestroika among the establishment and
I have to say this continues to inspire
me as
a magazine which when it's doing its job
arouses the animosity of the
establishment or pushes the taboos Nadia
has personally experienced the tragedy
of Russian journalism her husband Yuri
chequered sheikhan an extraordinary
investigative reporter who did some of
the great investigative work in very
difficult times during the Brezhnev
years during the perestroika years and
exposing abuses of power and corruption
which have led a new generation to
follow in his footsteps he was
mysteriously poisoned well he was
investigating a story of abuse of power
and corruption the investigation
continues perhaps we'll talk about that
in the context of journalists and the
problems of impunity with journalism in
Russia and Nadia has just finished
working on a documentary about Yuri
checker chickens life but even more a
life of a dissenting muckraking
journalist in Russia which was aired at
the dome at the house of journalists at
the end of november so let me begin if I
could and I'll do this just because I
want to give a sense of not just
thinking about the freedom of the press
in Russia over time and her reflections
on where it is heading and then we'll
start with a question and have a
conversation this is Nadia in 2007 in an
essay on freedom of the press and Russia
quote I cannot agree with colleagues
from Russia and the West who simply
announced the end of free speech in
Russia and the rise of a new ideological
terror blaming Putin's regime for
attacks on the Free Press I do not
nurture any illusions about the current
regime and its instruments however is a
lifelong member of the Russian
journalist community and as someone who
grew up in the Soviet Union during
dredgen of stagnation with its
atmosphere of hypocrisy and secrecy it's
discrepancy between claimed policy and
practices and it's combination of
courage and betrayal idealism and
cynicism I cannot agree that Putin's
regime and its lack of civil freedoms
are responsible for our current
situation I
suspect that the origins lie elsewhere
moreover the landscape of the Russian
and post-soviet medium media is
considerably more complex than is
usually presented in fact there's a
variety of trends competing within each
other among its hills and valleys it is
difficult in today's Russia to analyze
the media status and everyday
circumstances rather than to fall victim
to media simplification but the time for
such an analysis is long overdue very
powerful words so simplification
complexity one we have in large supply
the other not as much the complexity of
Russia and Russia's media maybe begin if
you might with a sense of taking on this
view that there's no press freedom of
any significant kind in Putin's Russia
something that this in some ways has
exposed it's not the case but was
certainly a prevailing view in this
country's coverage of Russia before this
maybe give us a sense of how you see the
status of press freedom and across print
radio television internet Thank You
Katrina first of all I do not know how
to behave after this enormous
presentation Thank You Katrina but I
would like to start with a share in very
unexpected feeling of enormous
inspiration which I got during today's
discussion here and it came it brought
me back to our wonderful and romantic
90s and late eighties when we were full
of expectations hopes and we really
believed that we participated in history
this feeling that you write and make
made sense that you could make
difference in your publication in your
environment in the in the whole huge
enormous surrealistic country like
Soviet Union and we understood that our
words had real power our words had
some material importance and our
discussion made sense for our readers
and many people now I got back this
almost forgotten feeling of open
discussion and discussion about
profession and this feeling gives hope
that we could overcome and we should
overcome many obstacles we have
intelligence in our profession here and
there and we all together could
establish this bridge this dialogue
between professionals and people
interested in not only history not only
some scholar things but in everyday
practice and this dialogue should be
established like we believed in the
beginning of 90s alike we believe during
perestroika between both Americans and
Russians and all we came shadows and
monsters of Cold War which we have been
discussing a lot but not enough today
and about simplification I do believe
that simplification is the worst enemy
of free speech of free quality and
responsible media in Russia in the
United States in the global scale and it
is enemy of democracy it is enemy of
open dialogue it is enemy of trust
simplification now view and global
economical crisis or crisis which is not
so global as we fill in Russia is our
everyday practice is commonplace
everything is simplified Putin's policy
Kremlin's decisions protests or anti
protests interventions in the media role
of journalists role of audience dialogue
between audience and journalists and
simple human values I would like to
remind myself the very title of our
conference images and consequences or
probably new stages of Cold War
cold war it was mentioned by Jonathan
sander so that cold war was fruitful in
many ways and I completely agree i was a
child of Cold War I do remember very
well details on our everyday life I
remember since I remember myself
propaganda TV programs much more brutal
and awful than today I should say but
sometimes more sophisticated at the same
time and I remember Voice of America
every evening parents adult people were
all listening and discussing a lot and
this discussion was continuing during my
whole life until recent years discussion
about current events and these
discussions inspired ideas and
interpretations interpretation is
important and feedback of any media
message is important now we have a lack
of this discussion we have no enough
professional and general conversation
about ourselves and about values and
what is important urine so or during
Soviet time and urine Soviet part of
Cold War competition which was a huge
concept and I do believe that it gave a
lot for creativity in Russia in the
United States and promoted value of
education value of knowledge about the
United States of the America our beloved
enemy it was important to have this
table and beloved enemy it was very
emotional dialogue for the kids I
remember total cynicism during last
technician time remember it very well
but at the same time people was admiring
the enemy even if many people really
believe that AMERICA AMERICA not Soviet
Union but America was Empire of evil
competition between cosmonauts
and astronauts competition between
scholars complete bit competition
between firdous it was exciting it was
sophisticated to know American
literature and the teenagers were
reading Hemingway Updike dr. o Dreiser
every everything now they do not it was
sophisticated to have irony and to
reduce any tops anecdotes was one of the
nicest part of Cold War and of course
everybody was readin and writin between
the lines seeking four drops of truth it
was craft of writing and reading which
will also lost first of all I just want
to welcome collection we spoke of you
before you arrived and how you should be
here in the rolling found in William way
which became so important for the
women's movement in Russia but so we
just there was a panel that preceded
this with great enthusiasm for the value
of the internet and but the Internet in
many ways sparked helped spark this
though as we've talked about the
internet had already been sparking civic
activism around Russia weather was
Miguel kagael or the fight to preserve
the kinky forest so this was a follow-on
an important ways but you also sound
like you're worried and I know you teach
at the leading journalism school in
Moscow that a new generation is
entranced with the internet but perhaps
is not grounded in some of the important
ideas of journalism of press freedom of
quality journalism and more interested
in the clicks and the thrill and the
quickness of the Internet has read msgs
not quality journalism of course
internet in is a temptation internet is
fantastic think it's a fantastic toy but
it's only a tool it's a tool for
messages it's a tool for political
manipulation it's a tool for garbage
it's a tool for everything we shouldn't
great importance of internet despite oil
all profits we got from internet and
here is not its thanks internet this 10
minutes video with the music by
Prokofiev presented work and I would
recommend to those of you who would like
to get vivid pictures from recent events
pictures from the best Russian
photographers awarded many times in
Russia and abroad they filmed faces and
images of protest meetings at the
exhibition called or churana from sure
of chair of our Election Commission
mature oven era she just finished the
Moscow but it's available on YouTube and
it's really gives the impression of what
happened and faces of ordinary people
not senior subtract fortunately not our
politicians not opinion makers so which
we used to get from official media faces
of ordinary people and you will get
feeling of Russia that's important
because faces of Russia are not
presented almost at all in our new and
traditional media that's also a
consequence of our competition and
consequence of censorship which arranged
competition with a sensor now whom to
compete it's a question and I would also
like to raise an issue of personal
choice we were talking about concepts
about the media models about economy
politics and so on but journalism as a
personal think it's a personal choice
and each of us must have choice every
minute people who just presented their
experience during last panel they did
they chose and each blogger each young
journalist each person which has not any
in education and probably doesn't and
identify himself or herself as a
journalist given information they give
their choice and it's crucial
we do not discuss our choices and
personal choice and personal dignity and
thus pouchon the frames and borders
during perestroika it was important ah
people experienced very strong pressure
from all possible sites not like today
they made their choice they all we came
many people today did not and just don't
think about that and what about journal
students don't can't mention that
students from argh ago were not
interested in our strong canvas tegay
shin or protests or even in ethical
standards of their work let's through
some young journalists and some students
do not but many of them do and I was
surprised when I started discussing with
our students what who decided to devote
themselves to journalists investigation
about their priorities and what what do
they think about profession they have
the same values as we had long ago
people from way I mean people from a
gang of magazine for example literate or
nagasawa miskovsky Nastya so they are
ready even to sacrifice they understand
that it could be and sometimes is
dangerous they would like to do their
best so they have motivation it's not
visible on the national media field but
those people exist in many towns and big
cities in many universities and those
students I think they will show their
talent and their work in the nearest
future and internet will help them but
what is also important it is also to
promote discussion about distinction
between the freedom of information and
freedom of speech between public
relations service and journalism
journalism as a public good and some
productions a media production which
sure can
follow different tendencies interests
and so on now do you spend quite a bit
of time at the union of journalists in
defending journalists from threats in
trying to expose the beatings of
journalists like Alec oisin and also
just telling the awful numbers of those
who have been killed how dangerous is it
to be a journalist in Russia today I
asked because it is it is clear that it
is dangerous on the other hand in this
country if you asked an average American
and I hate that term what they know
about Russia they would say that they
kill journalists or Putin kills
journalists he murdered someone in
London and so on if you could give us
the context of the killing of
journalists and I mean going back two
decades and how it's linked to the power
and property and corruption of Russia in
just a few of one how dangerous into a
history of how we have seen the
emergence of this pattern of killings
and beatings of journalists thank you
very much first of all there is a small
Russian language publication we produced
for December 15 day which is memorial
day 4 cubed journalists in Russia we
have this day for more than 10 years and
the families and colleagues of killed
and deceased people gather it's very
important event when we when we try to
raise awareness of professional society
and society as a whole to the simple
notion that safety of journalists safety
of democracy safety of state and it's a
profit of state not unfortunately many
people still do not
standard we have a database it's a
result of our cooperation together with
international federation of journalists
and the number of colleagues and
monitoring organizations we created two
databases first is devoted to a deceased
journalists killed disappeared died in
the unclear situation in this list we
have 333 names and detailed or less
detail the more detailed description on
on those cases the effect erection of
law enforcement convictions reaction of
community reaction of general public
politicians and so on and it's really
helpful to understand what is really
going on in this field second database
which is really new is devoted to all
conflicts in the media and it is
important that this database gathers
information on intimidations different
forms of censorship beatings firing
complains to court and also the whole
story and behold that this database it's
this very moment only Russia could be a
tool for sort of public control
transparency and real powerful tool in
our combatant impunity with which is a
real disease of Russian society we get
some fresh signs we were very inspired
by a president medvedev attention to our
complaints to our demands he invited
president of russian union of
journalists for discussion devoted to
midi issue safety of journalists status
of journalism which is very important
social and legal status of journalism
public broadcasting and freedom of
expression as well he promised to follow
all those i think it was 35 suggestions
for him president PDF
paid attention to assassination of
Natalie's T mera babu row and Mark Ellis
and fortunately once for the first time
in many years nor durs of marquee 11
Babu of the Putin to jail it was very
important very symbolic was a new
version of special law devoted to that I
was responsible for damage to
journalists and this crime is now
understood as a serious crime with
serious punishment for that we hope this
law must work and we'll do our best
together with media lawyers with all
colleagues and human right activists to
promote this work but talking about
safety of journalists and visibility of
this issue I think Russia suffers from
lack of solidarity and lack of trust
among journalists among society as a
whole and what is really needed is a
will we do believe that we need open
discussion about hot issues about our
policy about our everyday life about all
the tales of Russian life international
life which we do not have enough and we
need we do really need media education
it's another thing because our decision
makers are illiterate in media issue
some of them simply believe honestly
that it's enough just to pay several now
a number of chief editors and everything
will be decided everything will be fine
for them or to pay for some public
relations company to improve automate
image or to make some stupid and not
professional at all films like this film
we have been discussing recently I
should say that during Soviet I'm times
most a part of official machine-gun
propaganda straight propaganda was more
professional mate no and lack of
professionalism lack of professional
training for all media workers is also
disease of our society lack of
professionalism as disease of many of
our ministries many of our spheres and
it should be improved this is a
universal problem another universal
problem now we've talked a lot about
this there's a view particularly in
America that for free press to flourish
private ownership is demanded and you
know because you have traveled that
there are many different models of
ownership and the nation's john nichols
and robert mcchesney have written quite
a bit about perhaps independent state
funding but i'm interested in your sense
at this moment what is the current
status of ownership of russian media in
relation to press freedom and to give a
sense of the history of perhaps again
going back to the 90s we were talking
earlier about NTV that we are looking at
some of the legacy of the oligarchical
ownership of media now with fusion of
state control as well so how do you see
it at this moment thank you very much
for this question I should also confess
that Americans are responsible for
consequences of Cold War first of all
for images and illusions and fantasmas
of free world free market free economy
and freedom of expression and we now try
to overcome some of those illusions I
remember very well how my colleagues
much older than me that time at the
sophisticated perfect people so-called
architects of pillsbury stroke episode
sharm by market economy as an idea as a
paradise they never lived in they had no
any idea what to do how to arrange
things in market economy but it was like
a paradise to the contrary or also hit
hell of course and I do remember how
during perestroika
stover night TV reports made by perfect
reporters switched off from shifted from
spring attacks of workers in the same
building can solve bronx it was the same
building two glass windows from Fifth
Avenue with enormous luxury there was
nothing can Russia that time it was
deficit there was not enough food in the
stores long lines for milk bread and
sewn and glass windows it's our future
and many people really believed that it
must be it will be definitely our future
plus Russian gifted Intelligencer would
amaze and must amaze the universe with
its talents until every second will be
rich we in a gang of magazine which was
one of the most popular publications we
had much smaller salary than people from
prov the newspaper we belong to the same
publishing house we thought it was not
fair we arranged the first process for
our independence we everybody was crazy
with the market competition and so on we
really believed that we will be rich and
amazed everybody with our liberal ideas
we failed and very soon just after free
market came but all publishing houses
facilities still belong to the state we
had no money to live on and this
illusion that Russia without serious
experience in market in strong
psychological psychological heritage
from socialism and this idea of social
solidarity between people that this
country could follow pure Russian for a
pure market economy it failed and many
people literally died when my colleagues
here and there look at the numbers of
people they shouldn't die during those
times of transformation because of
because of crime
because of lack of social care because
of lots of things because of
psychological stress they didn't deserve
it and people lost illusions in
democracy instead of implementing proper
things from market economy and what
about me we have no market economy in
our media field of course there was a
small survey conducted conducted by the
union of journalists and the on the
regional level among political
newspapers and other publications only
two percent of all publications are
private and they're not the best all the
rest it's about political newspapers and
magazines the rest private old devoted
is devoted to entertainment of different
forms TV guides and so on I am talking
about press the rest is associated
directly or indirectly to state and
recent idea of and you know about
channels MTV officially is not
state-owned channel officially a Gordon
dello it's private of course its
associated very strongly with the
governmental institutions a new idea of
President Medvedev is a new way wave of
privatization and many people concern in
the regions especially that those who
would privatized previously governmental
media would be the same old girls from
Moscow mostly and some oligarchs already
circulating the country agitating for
this privatization it will be very
harmful it will be very harmful for
small media company I thought he also
proposed of this may gonna word the idea
of public television public television
is a great idea but he proposed today he
proposed we had a discussion of public
about public television a couple of
discussions we also had a discussion
about legislation on internet after that
emails and blocks of the most active
participants were ruined by some hackers
it's new phenomena but the question is
what channel could be given to this
public broadcasting and more serious
question what journalists will be
working for that broadcasting and who
will be chief editor it's a question and
when we are talking about making real
difference it's important to invest in
two people because people raising the
awareness during stagnation time they
arranged perestroika so we end first of
them were those working for
anti-american propaganda swell like mr.
Posner and other people from ghost
Colorado this foreign division and once
one word about forms of property
Scandinavian model which combines
private and public property probably
could be the most lucky for this very
moment for Russia but it needs some
public awareness it needs some public
some public bodies between those who
give governmental of public money and
those who arrangers editorial policy let
me ask you to more questions in an open
it up you travel around the provinces
yes quite a bit and over the last few
years we've talked a little bit about
the cable station in Tomsk and the
Solidarity there when journalists were
censored or the alte project yes tell us
just a little briefly about what you see
in the regions because after all Moscow
is not Russia New York Mossad the United
States and if the internet penetration
there is not very high and people are
still getting most of their news from
television what are the possibilities
for more attention to the issues of the
day in
parts Moscow is not rochette oh and
travel and circulation circulating all
over Russia you could feel like you
travel in time machine you could jump
you already had the information from the
Caucasus but I came two weeks ago I came
from Meriel Republic in the center of
volga region and I had a feeling that I
came it's very short several hours train
from Moscow orgonite train like I
traveled in the mid-70s in some regions
you could feel like you're jumped to
medieval stage in some feeling like to
the ninth though it's lots of diversity
and media situation is divorcing is also
diverse not like from one region to know
not not the same and unfortunately we
have no one united or universal
information space despite internet in
nature that doesn't cover the whole
Russian audience and we have huge
digital gap between regions settlements
big cities and generations and is very
harmful like we live we have several
Russia's and in some in some places like
the same p.m. ski cry there is no even
governmental institution devoted to
media policy they have lots of in the
they have no state-owned small
newspapers as well doesn't mean that
freedom of expression is flourishing
there it's more complicated in some
regions like Altai there is background
for independent development in even for
private media and we have Association of
India independent regional publishers
several dozens of organizations medium
and small very interesting in some
regions pressure is real tough in Moscow
region outside Moscow for exam
because of order in the governor
administration all governmental old
newspapers which is ninety-eight
ninety-seven percent of all print media
and they are very many they are like 11
thousand and a half numbers of the media
in one region they sent their plans and
sometimes print copies to the
administration first and get back and
after that after publication also sent
already printed and distributed copy
because it's easier for them because
they get money from this administration
and administration is stupid enough to
arrange this military order military
looking order but they're for my
military people it's it's so 70 minutes
driving from Moscow in Siberian much
more interesting picture so it's very
diverse but people are everywhere and
this is the most important point and
design sign of hope last question for me
you have spent much of your life
fighting for gender equality writing
about gender equality as editor of Wayne
way helping with journalism to nurture a
woman's movement so where does the media
in terms of covering women feminism
where is it now assess it have we have
you have you fought hard so we have
Sonya sub Chaka as the leader of Russian
women and is it the case that in these
protests one doesn't see many women
there are a few but not many women
leaders have emerged there so I'm cute
give us your sense of where it all
stands after all your years of first of
all I should confess that we face real
disaster in Russian journalism is
totally from a
you dominated field when I was a young
journalist we were 5050 of course all
bosses love male natural medium levels
some of them now one could hardly find
any male face in small editorial office
even driver no man at all our struggle
for gender justice should be recruitment
for young professionals I'm absolutely
serious so I try to explain this
phenomena to our colleagues and
international federation of journalists
they are fighting for number of women
profession we have big number of chief
editor some of them are really awful but
what to do feel quality of journalism is
diminishing status of journalism and
Trust to journalism this is better than
10 years ago but it's still low it is
very bad paid it is really dangerous to
be a sort of investigator a sort of in
small town is much more dangerous than
to criticize Putin's policy or ministers
in Moscow in sophisticated publication
it could really make problems make
problems for your family for your
children for your property your car and
you you could face lots of difficulties
so status of journalism should be
improved and of course leaders of the
biggest media are male they will be male
the most serious consequence of this
feminization of profession will be that
in 10 yes probably all graduate all
people graduated from Faculty of
journalism lots of faculties of
journalism will be women but Chiefs and
Managing Editors will be males with
probably some degree in economy but not
in journalism without any idea about
ethics and quality standards and about
this profession as a whole we should do
something present and what about
coverage coverage is minimum feminism is
not an issue it was it was an issue in
our policy during year since time
Yeltsin wanted to promote his importance
and he published several amendments
devoted to recruitment of women to
decision making to some equality stuff
and so on there was even a party women
mob parts a group a block of women in
Parliament many years ago but now it's
not an issue feminist movement was
puzzled because of financial and
personal and the general reasons and
ksenia sobchak is understood by many
people as a journalist unfortunately
like Lolita a pop star and other a
little lolita she was young journalist
defined here as a journalist and role
model self-made woman rich one senior
sap Chuck during those protest events
really attracted attention of media but
it played very harmful role in some way
and those workers who intended to create
a movement against those entire enemies
who protested against very nice and
great current power and leadership
looking and this senior subsequent for Q
code they had no any sympathy to her
because for some youngsters for stupid
teenagers probably she is something but
for many people she is not at all and
senior subject is an interesting
phenomenon to discuss to study but we
have no really strong leaders at the pro
at the demonstration dev of few women
but this movement didn't use a resource
of women's activism like democracy and
my favorite Eve lynskey never used
activism of women in Russia when they
had a sort of power it was a big mistake
wanted to open it up could I go here
could I go here and then I think so yeah
briefly I think I appreciated your
comments on the fringe benefits of the
Cold War the American legal system was
based upon an adversary system and I
think it worked a lot of what the
Soviets said about capitalism should
have been said and vice versa there was
nothing wrong with it ah but I
discovered the time reading the Soviet
press and the American present there are
two ways to keep the public from knowing
anything one is to tell them nothing the
Soviet system then you look under
McGrattan and the other is to tell them
everything but bury the crucial stuff on
page 47 of section 2 of the New York
Times that only the Soviet delegate at
the UN ever read and so he quoted the
New York Times frequently and it looked
very democratic the other thing is I can
an example of the usefulness of this
contrariness was I was at a meeting of
the UN an economic meeting and the
soviet and american delegations were
discussing the respective urges of their
systems and the American delegate for
once did something intelligent he
brought to the next meeting a Sears and
Roebuck catalogue which pretty much
ended the discussion but what I want to
ask to know about some of us associate
about the Russian journalism what you
have to do to become a journalism if you
want an advanced degree in journalism
it's some news on what books do you have
to read what examinations do you have to
to take written oral is there a
filtering process to make sure
undesirables don't get through thank you
I think sears and roebuck just went into
bankruptcy why don't we take a few and
then Nadia could okay thank you Nadia
again I'm dr. pol nur and I president of
cinema better to international inc I
know you need that for the cameras i
just--can sitting here I find what you
say very very interesting your construct
of the time machine since I spent a lot
of time in outside of Moscow and st.
Pete I feel as if I'm a time machine but
one of the benefits is I always feel
younger because I go back in time and I
remember New York City that looks like
some of those cities when I was younger
some of the Russian cities my second
point though is about I be I've taught
as a professor in New York University's
for years other than I lectured at
Columbia but when you go to many of the
public universities in the United States
they know absolutely nothing about
Russia so you said they know this or
that but they know nothing they have no
idea that there's a separate entity
called Ukraine or Kazakhstan or the
Russian Far East will happen they know
nothing okay and that is totally tragic
and to make a major example of that
Jonathan Sanders was telling me before
he left that he teaches at Stony Brook
now but nobody knows that he was a
Russian specialists journalist he only
teaches journalism but does not give
this man who's filled with information
says nothing about Russia and you know
what this because Americans are not
particularly interested and that is most
unfortunate I just wanted to give you
that information if you want to respond
it's fine if not it was just sustainment
thank you hi I'd like to pick up on
something that you said earlier about
the importance of professionalization
and journalism education Russia in my
admittedly limited experience that would
be the light of you who correctly
this with journals and faculties
especially in go in Russia it's the case
that actually having more people go to
journalist and faculties will be kind of
productive because there is not just a
condescension that I I go to Columbia
durable school that exists in certain
quarters against journalism students
here there are actually entire
publications such as corrective arm come
come here songs which is also the only
Russian newspaper that has a
fact-checking department and ayesha that
have policies of not taking anyone from
the journalism faculty I have never even
come across a professional Russian
journalists again there's probably do my
limited experience of a relatively young
age who actually went to the journalism
school they they all studied economics
politics languages or something else
usually at the same University and so I
would like to know if there is a
correction a connection there and what
could be done in Russia to improve that
thank you thank you first of all I would
like to repeat that during the Cold War
time education was really important and
it was important also to it wasn't
important to use literary and the proved
Russian language quality of our main
tool language decreased enormously like
quality of journalism because of
different reasons and what about
education I was graduated from Moscow
Faculty of journalism and I had post
graduate course there I was criticized
that was when I was a student and I was
almost thrown from the University
fortunately I survived there I should
say that Moscow State University now and
I teach there now it was the main
faculty devoted to propaganda but of
course faculty of journalism
so I was studying propaganda now it is
called public relations and I was really
surprised when I came to my fellowship
to Canon Institute to study coverage of
Russia and I figure out that the main
points of those hated by all our
students were carefully studied and
implemented implemented in media and
many American media at the same time we
were studying propaganda and all
possible stuff how to make it a better
than today but after the break we had
studies devoted to officially forbidden
writers which was very difficult to
study in faculty of philology and I was
really touched with the effect that we
flew together with Grigory shred of
yesterday on aircraft named by Asik
mandelstam my diploma is aircraft su
number 315 I would recommend and choice
of Hollywood movies is much better than
on delta flight and my diploma was
devoted to awesome understand but it was
not direct it was cold war time he was
persecuted so he was he was not an
official poet so it was devoted to some
old traditions in intellectual
traditions in a contemporary Russian
poetry so we got lots of achievements
and old style of literary of yes
latricia focused education was very
important for journalists we have been
discussing in this small this morning
that diverse education for journalists
and university course for journalists is
real value and I would not like to
comment policy of Commerce
Sun newspaper or other newspapers we
have lots of private journal schools
quality of education is very problematic
but Moscow State University San
petersburg state university they still
keep some standards all professors had
special courses of special fellowships
in international in Western universities
so curriculum has changed a lot and now
they are transforming the opportunities
and I believe that young journalists and
some of students are really well
prepared so qualification for
journalists is really powerful tool and
education is also tool to protect
freedom of the media that's why it's
important to arrange different courses
and I would like also to mention that I
do believe that we need to establish to
reestablish dialogue between
professionals Russians and American
devoted to international studies to
investigative journalists exactly
because investigative journalism is
disappearing from Russian media and many
productions presented as investigations
are not at all so you should God get
back investigations and I would like
also to say that some media already
likely combine traditional and new forms
and the runners like caucasian knot and
others and already mentioned out the
press we have their fantastic
convergence newsroom and enterprise
there we could train our colleagues we
should share experiences and we had
already experienced and Cathy
participated as an adviser sponsored by
ir x between journalists from the united
states and russia it was devoted to
media management it was devoted to new
technologies and other stuff and do we
ended with the idea of dialogue of trust
and they hope this dialogue of trust
virtual
practical will come real on that note I
will hope that we continue our
collaboration Nadia in terms of making
sure there are more women in positions
of editorial leadership in Russia and
the United States and in collaborating
on investigative journalism because this
country to is seen a crisis but in many
new forms there is a revival and
resurgence and we needed in both
countries desperately so thank you for
your wonderful reflections thank you and
same cantina for your wonderful article
which you already translated into
Russian it's available about December
evolution and this approach from America
and what we didn't notice enough urine
our events also was very fruitful for us
we hope also to disseminate a December
evolution on behalf of the Harriman
Institute I'd like to thank Nadia and
Katrina first of all for a dazzling
ending to this conference and then move
on to thanking all of the panelists it's
the nature of a conference on journalism
that unfortunately they're not all here
because journalists have to go in and
out and it was wonderful to have the
extraordinary group of people here that
we were able to have here I want to
thank my co-sponsors I Harriman's
co-sponsors / Shapiro who is sitting in
the front row and Anya Shiffrin hood as
an extraordinary amount of work behind
the scenes although you have not seen as
much of her as we would have liked and
to the audience many of you have had
incredible staying Bauer so on that note
thank you all and go forth and think